Aber machst du vom Rand oder von innen? Machst du vom Rand oder von innen? Schon von innen, also so eine kleine... Das Problem, wenn du von innen, ich habe das Gefühl, wenn du von innen hast, dann hast du es im Endgame leichter, aber von außen kommst du auf jeden Fall schneller runter an das Angegum. Wir haben alles probiert. Diese ganzen Tricks, von denen du sprichst, sind alle Quatsch. Du musst, eigentlich musst du es umdrehen. Also wenn du die geballte, am an, nee, ganz kurz, ganz kurz, ganz kurz, ganz kurz, ganz kurz. Entweder du den Beil nehmen und das Durchhauen in der Mitte des Katil. Und dann von beiden Seiten hast du dann die geballte Experience.
Oder du rist es um.
Nachteil, kleberige Finger.
Dann verschmiert die Bio-Hausaufgaben für Herrn Meier.
Ich habe aber auch gehört, dass die absoluten Kratzeis-Cracks,
die auch schon umgedreht ins Gefrierfach tun,
damit wenn sie es dann aufmachen, dass das Süße ganz oben ist.
Aber das ist ja wohl, wie man immer so schön sagt, da bescheisst man nur sich selbst. Das ist genauso, wenn man in der Schule abschraut, da betrügt man nur sich selbst. Ja, und das deutsche Schulsystem, aber auch sich selbst, ja. Wo macht es schon ein Besonderes? Also auch auf zum Positiven hin. Aber selbst Abschauen und Spicken ist ja ein Skill. Ich finde ja immer, es ist ja in der Schule nicht so wichtig, was man lernt, sondern dass man lernt. Und vor allem auch, dass man das Lernen lernt. Weil der Inhalt... Wer hat das Fach Lernen, Lernen? Da dachte ich mir, wer lehrt das Fach Lernen, Lernen, Lernen? Ist das eine Nachhilfe für dieses Fach Lernen, Lernen, Lernen? Und das... na, ihr wisst schon. Macht den Gag mal weiter. Du bist mega gut in Mathe, aber schlecht in Lernen, Lernen. Moment mal, hey, Mars! Weil, ich meine, den ganzen Inhalt, den man in der Schule lernt, vergisst man eh wieder. Kannst du noch irgendwie die Mitternachtsformel oder was eine Fuge ist oder so? Ich habe mein Leben noch nicht von der Mitternachtsformel gehört. Hä, natürlich. PQ-Formel, meinst du vielleicht. B² plus minus vier AC Wurzel minus geteilt durch zwei AC irgendwas. Das ist der relativste Zene, Rie. Aber was genau dieses Plus minus bedeutet, weiss ich auch nicht. Weil das ist ja schon ein ziemlich krasser Unterschied, ob das ein Plus ist. Das sagt ich auch immer. Also das Gegensatz. Entscheidet euch mal. Das ist genauso wie in Latein, wo es das Wort Altus gibt und es heißt hoch und tief. Jesus Christ. Wörter haben Bedeutungen. Fang mal bitte einfach an, eine Sprache ernst zu nehmen. Auf manchen Fall sind solche Dinge einfach, da hat jemand dann sofort, stand vor der Tafel, Dominus, Altus est, und er dachte sich, ja, ihr passt jetzt folgendes, ihr passt entweder hoch oder tief.
Ich weiß nicht, wie groß Dominikus war, war er groß, war er klein, keine Ahnung. Ich finde aber gut, dass du gerade den Jochen Seinfeld gemacht hast mit Wörter haben Bedeutungen. Wörter haben Bedeutungen. Apropos Stand-Up-Comedy, du bist ja wieder bald auf den Bühnen Deutschlands zu sehen. Bald, Stefan wieder auf Tour. Ich freue mich ein bisschen, dass ich Gäste, also wenn ihr quasi den Podcast gehört habt, letzte Woche Donnerstag einen Auftritt hatte, weil ich wollte das noch nicht ankündigen, weil es ist mein zweiter Auftritt und ich habe Angst, dass Leute von euch hinkommen, die Erwartungen haben, die ich natürlich nicht erfüllen werde. Ja, wir haben ja alle den ersten Stand-Up-Auftritt von Stefan gesehen und mir und ich gebe auf, Stefan macht weiter. Rückblickend, habe ich es nochmal mal angehört, damals dachte ich mir, auch im Podcast habe ich noch mal angehört, unsere Reflektion, wie arrogant wir behauptet haben, wie gut unsere Auftritte waren. Die waren ganz schön scheiße. Also ich habe mir das noch mal rückblickend angehört und dachte mir, vielleicht kannst du davon was übernehmen. Nein, das war echt ganz schön schlecht. Also ich fand nichts gut. Ich habe danach nämlich allen immer gesagt, ja, ich mache nicht weiter aus dem Grund, weil der erste Auftritt, der war zu gut, als dass man das nochmal besser machen würde, wollen würde. Und der war aber auch nicht so gut, dass man das jetzt jede Woche braucht. Und das habe ich immer gesagt. Und deswegen dachte ich, der wäre gut, aber der war gar nicht so gut. Ja, die Eule der Minerva fliegt erst nachts. Oder tags, je nachdem, was das Wort heisst.
Ist es ein altes Sprichwort, kann gut sein, dass die mittlerweile ihren Biorhythmus geendet haben. Eulen, oder? Hey, ich habe gestern so lange über das Wort Eulen nachgedacht. Ich schwöre euch, ja bestimmt eine halbe Stunde lang bin ich durch die Wohnung gelaufen, wo ich nichts anderes getan habe, als über das Wort Eule nachzudenken. Aber nur das Wort, nicht das Tier Eule. Macht mal einen Jux mit euch und guckt es dann nicht nach, ob das existiert, weil du zweifelst nach Minute zwei an dem Wort Eule. Du denkst, ach so. Was willst du jetzt haben? Du greifst massiv ausladend über den Tisch. Nur kurz die Flasche, danke. Welchen denn? Die. Aber es ist tatsächlich, vor allem bei Eule muss ich immer an die Situation hängen, ich spiele ja DSA. Die Korken knallen. Die Kronkorken fliegen. Folge 98. Lass mal anstoßen. Auf 98 Folgen Podcasts für meine Güte. Die 100 kommt viel zu rapide. Wir müssen es besser machen. Wir haben noch nichts vorbereitet. Grosse Pläne, aber keine Motivation, die umzusetzen. Und bei DSA, da rettet man ja immer die Welt, man spielt irgendwie Krieger und Druiden, die alle die Welt retten, aber ich bin ja ein Comedy Freak, das heißt, ich habe eine sehr ernste Figur, ich spiele einen Schwarzmagier, der sehr ernst ist und die Dinge immer sehr ernst nimmt. Das ist die gesamte Charakterbeschreibung meines, gerade das, den ich jetzt seit vier Jahren spiele, er nimmt alles ernst. Okay, und da gab es aber auch mal eine Situation, wo wir eine hochrangige Hexe treffen sollten. Ganz kurz. Und dann wurden wir von, und jede Hexe hat ein Tier, also ein Gefolgstier, und diese Hexe hatte eine Eule. Und diese Hexe hat nach uns gesandt und hat ihre Eule geschickt und dann kam die Eule zu uns und hat uns zu verstehen gegeben, dass wir der Eule folgen sollen. Und dann sind wir der Eule hinterher gelaufen, durch den Wald, und dann haben wir die Eule so ein bisschen verloren oder aus der Sicht verloren, dann habe ich gesagt, hey Leute, damit wir die nicht verlieren, glaube ich, wir sollten uns beäulen. Und es war so viel am Platz und es war dann so, würfel mal Charisma. Das ist die beste, die beste Reaktion auf den Witz ist, würfel mal Charisma. Ja, dann gehen wir vierzehn. Ja, dann wollen wir vielleicht noch Pizza bestellen, wir sind gerade spät. Ja, wir feln mal auf Telefon. Das war Pen und Paper. Ich glaube, ich habe jetzt auch angefangen, mit ein paar Freunden in Star Wars Pen und Paper zu spielen. Und es ist schon cool, was da für Situationen entstehen. Und ich bin ein Hacker. Ein Hacker-Genie spiele ich. Weißt du, du kannst alles sein. Du kannst in Romeo sein, Verführungsheld, Kletterer, Athlet, du kannst springen, hüpfen, Raumschiffen fliegen. Und ich spiele etwas zu grossen, schlagsigen, im Comedy-Industrie gefangenen 20-Jährigen. Ja, und ich mag Computer. Ich mag es, wenn man mit Computern Sachen machen kann. Zurecht werden manche von euch jetzt die Frage stellen, hast du denn die Macht? Nein. Bist du sonst irgendwie cool? Nein. Ich bin ein Hacker und mein Problem ist, dass ich mich nicht so sehr identifizieren kann. Heute hat mir jemand einen Server-Link geschickt und ich habe es geschafft, den zu eröffnen, wollte er erst dieses Hackerman-Gift machen, was alle von Mr. Robert immer schreiben, weil ich so stolz darauf war, es geschafft zu haben. Ich habe nicht so viel mit Hackern am Hut und Hacken. Und deswegen habe ich das, kann ich mich nicht so sehr identifizieren damit. Und dann hat jeder Spieler halt so eine Pflicht, die seine Vergangenheit ihm mit auf den Weg geht. Bei mir wäre das dann, ich soll das Imperium auf Wegen schaden, mit denen das Imperium nicht rechnet. Halt mit meinen Fähigkeiten. Glaube die Baupläne. Mit meinen Fähigkeiten. Leider Gottes weiß ich nicht genau, was mit Hacken alles möglich ist. Und bin dann kreativ auch auf eine Grenze gestossen. Ich habe jetzt ein Virus ans Imperium geschickt. In so das Spam-Mail. In das Spam-Mail, exakt. Und zwar heißt es Wartungsarbeiten Hangar 7, habe ich die genannt, eine Mail. Und da drin habe ich ein Virus programmiert, da muss ich noch auf Computertechnik würfeln, und habe es geschafft. Und jetzt habe ich ein Virus, der ein paar Daten, aber auch nicht nur zu viele, nur so ein paar Daten löscht, mit denen man so eine Wartungsfrau, so eine Maintenancefrau, die da einfach sitzt und jetzt eine Mail öffnet wahrscheinlich. Aber das wäre ein ganz anderer Film gewesen, wenn das Imperium durch eine Spam-Mail zu Fall gebracht worden wäre. Ich dachte mir auch bei Rogue One, machen die einen Gag daraus? Ich meine, die müssen die Pläne ja nicht händisch erlangen, die können die auch einfach hacken. Das ist einfach die ganze Zeit so ein Red Bull-Schreibtisch, so ein Kammerspiel. Ja, man starrt auf so einen Ladebalken die ganze Zeit. Ja, stimmt schon. Ihr merkt schon. Wir sind gerade ein bisschen damit beschäftigt. Krass als zu essen, primär. Das ist eine Feierabendfolge. Wir kommen heute mal ein bisschen runter. Irgendwie, es war ein langer Tag. Irgendwie, was habt ihr erlebt bei der Uni? Schreibt es auf ein Blatt Papier. Und ansonsten... Wir haben eine Menge Mails bekommen. Es ist wirklich teilweise so ein bisschen Jesus-Status. So, wenn du so was sagst... Von Gott. Ja, aber Jesus ist ein bisschen gesprächiger als Gott gewesen, soweit ich weiß, aber der sagt dann sowas wie, ah, Leute hier, kein Schweinefleisch, ich mag kein Schweinefleisch, und plötzlich wird zu einer jahrtausendalten Dogma erhoben, dass man kein Schweinefleisch essen darf, so ist es bei uns mittlerweile auch geworden, dass wir uns so fragen, so, hm, wie ist das eigentlich bei weiblicher Kleidung, wie kriegt man eigentlich eine weibliche Bluse auf, und plötzlich wir 500 Mails, die sagen, dass es tatsächlich so ist, wie wir in der letzten Folge behauptet haben, und zwar, dass männliche und weibliche Kleidung anders geknüpft wird, also auch bei Blusen und Hemden, also es geht darum, ob in der Knopfreihe welche Seite unten und welche oben ist. Ich habe auch viele Schritte von Frauen geschickt bekommen, wo das nicht so war, wo es halt genauso war wie bei Männern. Danke an diese ganzen Einsendungen. Ja, vielen Dank dafür. Und schick mir vielleicht auch eine Nummer dazu ein. Und vor allem, ich habe zwei Theorien gehört, warum das so ist. Eine Theorie lautet, ich glaube, die kann ich sogar vorlesen, wir können mal ein bisschen Male vorlesen. Weil Frauen angekleidet wurden früher, ne? Ja, cool, jetzt können wir das auch nochmal vorlesen. Jetzt habe ich so eine, ich bin sehr tief in so eine, ich habe so eine Art Minenschach gebaut und jetzt bin ich sozusagen im Herzen des Kratzerrackers vorgedrungen. Problem ist, wenn man sich die Kratzerrackurve anschaut im Sinne von Zeit und Genuss, Zeit auf der X-Achse, Genuss auf der Y-Achse, hast du quasi wie so einen Pickel. Erst fängt es sehr anstrengend an, nervig, nervig, nervig, dann kommst du plötzlich ans Ziel.
So eine, da ist die geballte Power und dann sinkt es wieder so ein bisschen ab und hinten raus,
hast dann halt wieder das Dreckseis, was ja dann die letzten Reste, die meistens auch keinen Geschmack mehr drin haben,
wo sie einfach so ein bisschen das Wasser gefroren hat.
So viel zu Katze als Exper-Erfahrungen.
Kein Problem.
Komm ruhig rein.
Heute ist auch die Sachen. Heute kann man auch mal rausgehen.
Das ist so eine Folge, wo man auch mal
rausklogen kann. Ich habe die Mel nicht gefunden,
aber die Theorie darin lautete folgendermassen,
dass Frauen
früher angekleidet wurden von
Kammerzofen und deswegen
die Kleidung andersrum ist. Aber da denke ich mir,
das ist ja eigentlich keinen Sinn, weil wenn die Kammerzofen
Vielen Dank. dass Frauen früher angekleidet wurden von Kammerzofen und deswegen die Kleidung andersrum ist. Aber da denke ich mir, das ist ja eigentlich keinen Sinn, weil wenn die Kammerzofen auch Frauen sind, müssen sie dann wieder... Also die Idee ist ja, dass du dich selbst andersrum ankleidest als andere Menschen. Was für tragische Männer, die Frauen ankleiden mussten. Das Gegenteil von dem, was sie eigentlich wollen, sie ankleiden. Ich habe einen habe einen gag gemacht ich bin so hässlich frauen bezahlen mich dass ich mich anziehe frauen ziemlich mit ihren blicken an ah ja oh habe ich sogar letztens doch was ähnliches ist dann leider gottes anziehen ist falsch zu verstehen scheiße das kann man auch nicht umgehen glaube ich wir haben folgenden einen Kommentar bekommen, fand ich sehr lustig, von Simon. Er fängt nach einer Frage. Warum höre ich diesen Podcast immer noch? Ich bin übergewichtig, älter als ihr, lauche E-Zigarette, benutze Fragen wie zum Bleistift und finde die blasser, dünner, junge Gags immer noch lustig. Alles Punkte, über die ihr inzwischen euren Unmut kundgetan habt. Wahrscheinlich bin ich doch nur gespannt, in was für Gruppen mich noch ballen, die ihr nicht leiden könnt oder ich bin masochistisch veranlagt. Ja, dazu fand ich super lustig. Sorry, ey, im Ernst, wir machen hier, weißt du, das ist so eine reale Folge. Ja, ich glaube, du bist einfach der schlechteste Mensch der Welt, das tut mir leid, aber wir haben ihn langsam gefunden. Ich wollte gerade mal die Ironiehülle fallen lassen und sagen, wir meinen das ja alles nicht so. Wir hauen einfach nur in alle Kerben. Ich meine das schon so. Ich finde Leute, die zum Gleichnis sagen, wie scheiße. Nein, doch. Nee, du kannst nicht immer dir das Ruder reißen. Nee, weißt du was? Nee, du kannst ja Eigenschaften einer Person scheiße finden und trotzdem die Person gut finden. Nur weil du diese eine Eigenschaft nicht gut findest. Du kannst ja auch sagen, hey, keine Ahnung, du hast jetzt nicht die richtigen politischen Eigengedanken wie ich. Aber ich finde ihn trotzdem cool. Das ist doch die wahre Toleranz. Nicht, dass man immer behauptet, alles sei toll, sondern dass man sagt, auch wenn Dinge scheiße sind, dass man sich trotzdem noch cool finden kann. Das ist doch die wahre Toleranz. Ich finde, wahre Toleranz ist auch, Klischees zu akzeptieren. Wenn angenommen mal ein Schwuler in gewisse Klischees fällt, im Ernst, bald kursiert ihr vielleicht ein Sketch zum Thema, der sich mit dem Filetmesser dieses Thema annimmt und genau zitiert, wie es von uns erwarten könnte, satirisch.
Und da ist es doch so, dass es manchmal, glaube ich, auch für Homosexuelle schwierig ist, einem Klischee zu entsprechen.
Was ist das denn für eine spannende Diskussion eigentlich? Angenommen, ich bin schwul und höre liebe Musicals. Wow, die Gesellschaft verlangt von mir mittlerweile so, so eine Schwule sind auch normal Nummer. Aber tatsächlich ist es ja nicht schlimm, wenn man auch mal Klischees entspricht. Da ist ja nichts dabei. Das ist ja auch cool. Das ist wahre Toleranz, das zu erkennen. Die aktuelle Zeit, die Zeitung, die Zeit titelt diese Woche, wir können ja mal ein bisschen in Journalismus einsteigen, die Zeit titelt diese Woche mit Marie Le Pen und auf der Titelseite stellt sie so ein paar Fragen, die in der Ausgabe diskutiert werden, unter anderem die Frage, warum spricht niemand darüber, dass sie eine Frau ist? Und das war echt eine Schlagzeuge, wo ich mir dachte so, what? Also ist es denn nicht genau mega gut, wenn niemand darüber diskutiert, dass sie eine Frau ist? Das ist doch genau da, wo man hin will. Und da habe ich mir auch gedacht. Wo wollte der Artikel denn hin? Habe ich nicht gelesen, aber ich dachte mir einfach nur so, wenn man diese Frage stellt, dann rudet man schon wieder in die andere Richtung. So, ah, okay, wir haben akzeptiert, dass Frauen auch scheiße sein können und dass Frauen auch die Welt in den Ruinen stürzen können.
Cool, Gleichberechtigung, aber dann kommt jemand, ja, warum erwähnt das niemand? Ich glaube, dieser Sexismus... Hat mich enttäuscht von der Zeit. Eigentlich, ich lese die Zeit gerne, aber da habe ich gesagt, nö. Ich habe manchmal gedacht, wo wäre diese Sexismusdebatte jetzt eigentlich, wenn Hitler eine Frau gewesen wäre? Einfach so eine fette Frau. Aber vielleicht gab es noch jemanden, eine viel kompetentere Hitlerfrau, die aber nicht an die Macht kam, weil sie eine Frau war. Das ist der wahre Skandal. Ja, und die hätte viel effizienter Juden vergast. Ja, aber wäre das dann gut gewesen oder nicht? Weiß ich nicht, in deren, also in ihrem Welt schon, aber naja. In ihrem Welt. Also nur weil es Juden sind, haben sie nicht eine komplett andere Grammatik. Die haben für mich keine richtige Präpositionen verdient. Gar nichts, einfach. Dann fand ich auch sehr lustig, von
ähm, Punkt. Noch nie habe ich das
Wort Teflon jemals benutzt noch gehört.
Und dann kam gestern, ein paar Stunden
nach Hören des Podcasts, fragt mein Mitbewohner
ganz was selbstverständlich, ob ich denn
sein Teflon gesehen hätte, kam nicht drumrum
und musste ihn auslachen, irgendwie lustig,
irgendwie gruselig. Das kennt man ja, selektive Wahrnehmung, man hört etwas nicht, bis man es mal gehört hat und sozusagen eine Schleuse öffnet und dann merkt man plötzlich, dann nimmt man das wahr, es hilft sozusagen, also je mehr Dinge man sich bewusst macht, desto mehr sieht man dann auch nicht mehr nur peripher. Und ich glaube, das ist wirklich ein Ding, was man als jemand, der wie wir in der Comedy
arbeitet, abstellen muss. Solche Dinge müssen einem auffallen, ohne dass jemand einen drauf
bringt. Oder man muss halt so viel ... Ja, das ist eigentlich die wahre Kunst.
Aber das überlassen wir gestern ist der Geisterbahn. Soll ich mal ganz kurz? Ich bin gerade zusammen, ich habe jetzt einen Durchbruch, einen totalen Durchbruch. Wann du mal schaust? Oh ja, gut, aber jetzt hast du ein Problem, weil jetzt hast du es von unten ausgehöhlt. Ich weiß. Jetzt kannst du noch umdrehen. Gleich viel bis runter. Dann kam noch eine ganz tolle Nachricht von Neville Longbottom. Hier in Köln gibt es seit Herbst letzten Jahres auch eine Quillage-Mannschaft, Cologne Cannons. Könnt ihr mal vorbeischauen, um Footage für neue Gags zu sammeln, oder um euer Fit kann auch lustig in tausend Anführungszeichen geschrieben vorhaben umzusetzen. Kommt vorbei, um euch über uns lustig zu machen. Oder beides. Das finde ich sehr gut. Training, ich bitte mal, da hätte ich Anführungszeichen gemacht, ist jeden Samstag von 11 bis 13 Uhr auf der Wiese vor der Unimense. Der Schnatz ist übrigens ein Tennisball in einer Socke, die man aus der Hose des Schnatzläufers ziehen muss. Alles klar. Und es hat auch jemand geschrieben, dass man nicht automatisch gewinnt, wenn man den Schnatz fängt, sondern man lediglich 150 Punkte bekommt, wohingegen man für ein normales Tor einen halben Punkt bekommt. Das heißt, technisch gesehen kann man noch gewinnen. Warum war das Spiel dann vorbei, als Harry den Schnatz gefangen hat? Ich glaube, man kriegt 150 Punkte und wenn man dadurch dann gewinnt, dann ist das Spiel auch automatisch zu Ende. Weil dumm ist ja, wenn ein Spiel dann noch weiter geht, wenn es jetzt zwei zu 150 und es geht noch weiter, hat noch zehn Minuten. Kann auch einen Schnatz fangen. Anderen Schnatz, von einem anderen Feld. Oder einfach einen herzaubern. Wie wär's damit? Achio Schnatz. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist ein guter Punkt. Achio, äh, hier, Klopfer, wie heißen die in diesen anderen Bälle? Keine Ahnung, Quaffle. Klopfer. Hab acht vor dem Klopfer. Freut euch mal auf meinen Fantasy-Kosmos, wenn ich bald erinnere. Da hat alles ganz crazy Namen. Aber auch ein Fehler macht Quidditch. Und zwar geht es irgendwann ausserhalb des Feldes. Der Schnapp fliegt dann irgendwo anders rum, so in dem Himmel und sowas. Wo ich mir auch denke, what? Dann können die ja, dann muss ja das Feld, warum ist das Feld nicht so groß? Weil dann darüber hinaus kann das Spiel nicht weitergehen, da kann ja niemand mehr checken, da gibt es ja keine Schiedsrichter. Gibt es Schiedsrichter? Viele Fragen. Du kannst auch nicht anfangen, in der Wüste zu spielen, an dem das ist ein sicheres Stadion, und dann fliegt der Schnaz irgendwo raus und das ist dann saugefährlich. Das hat da so viele Lücken, die man mitdenkt. Was hindert einfach andere Leute daran, auch einfach mitzuspielen, die einfach auf ihren Besen dann mit ins Geschehen fliegen?
Und dann muss man sagen, komm, wir können, dann kann der Typ mit dem gelben Schal bitte kurz vom Spielfeld kommen, kann er bitte nicht den Klopfer die ganze Zeit in der Haft festhalten?
Aber ist das nicht auch das Problem beim normalen Fussball? Ich meine, da spielt ja auch nicht jemand, die jemand wird.
Das ist zweidimensional, da kannst du ja zumindest das abgrenzen, aber so kann ja einfach jemand, der sich verflogen hat, so sorry, sorry, fliegt ja einfach ins Geschehen ran. Das stimmt, die dreidimensional ist ein großes Problem. Auf allem, du kannst ja auch... Ja, oder auch generell so Gefängnisse oder irgendwas in der Richtung. Alles, wo du Menschen fern oder innehalten möchtest, kannst du komplett vergessen, wenn Harry Potter... Ich glaube, Filme zu drehen im Universum von Harry Potter wäre total easy, weil die haben zwar die Technik nicht, aber die hätten, die könnten eine Kamera fliegen lassen, schweben lassen. Das heißt, so Kamerafahrten oder die könnten die einfach programmieren, so mit einem Zauber oder so Kamerakräne wäre total easy. Ja, oder sie können einfach Accio, Hell der Ringe 2 und dann kommt der Film selbst herangeflogen. Es ist eine weirde Welt. Hat sich selber, hat sich selber gefilmt. Crazy Film.
So what?
Das waren so die Nachrichten von euch. Vielen Dank. Ich finde auch gut so ein Fändis aus einem Zwischen-Universum, wo Dinge zu einfach geworden sind.
Wo man einfach magischer ist, wenn du so, Akio Lebensglück, okay, ich bin glücklich, ciao, cool, coole Welt, macht Spaß hier, Akio Seelenverwandte, hi, hallo Maren, hallo cool, cool, freut mich, dich kennenzulernen, ciao, Akio Burger King Sparmenü.
Wurde trotzdem noch ein Sparmenü, nee.
Warum kann dir alles, wo kommt das Zeug eigentlich her, wenn das Akio 50 Euro?
Ich glaube, du musst schon in der Nähe dessen sein.
Du kannst, glaube ich, an so einem Burger King Stand stehen und sagen, Akio Sp 50 Euro. Ich glaube, du musst schon in der Nähe dessen sein. Also du kannst, glaube ich, an so einem Birking-Stand stehen und sagen, Akio, sparen wir. Dann kommt der Typ dir hinterhergelaufen und mit der wedelnden Faust, schick gleich meinen Klopfer los. Wir müssen über eine Sache sprechen, und zwar haben wir beide einen Artikel entdeckt. Also ich habe ihn entdeckt, ich bin besser von uns. Und zwar, wir hatten es lange für einen Scherz gehalten, aber es gab ihn... Ich war noch nie so enttäuscht von einem Artikel. Aber wollen wir kurz sagen ... Ich will es anders an moderieren. Der Background war, wir haben einen Twitter-Account gefunden, der hat immer nur ein paar Wörter geschrieben. Deshalb hat sich herausgestellt, dass der lustigste fucking Twitter-Account der ganzen Welt. Ich glaube, der hat so random Wörter generiert. Ja, das war so ein bisschen so ein Bot. Und der hat immer so Sachen getwittert, einfach so wirklich, ich glaube, teilweise so Wortpaare, einfach so irgendwie Shoe Fantasy, einfach irgendwie verschiedene Sachen. Und dann haben wir uns immer angeguckt, weil wir auf der Suche, weil wir auf der Suche waren Namen für gute Arbeit, haben wir lange nach dem Namen gesucht, wie man auch einen Namen feststellen kann. Wir hätten fast Shoe Fantasy geheissen. Aber wir können ja vielleicht mal... Das ZDF war dagegen. Ja, wir hätten fast Trash Panda geheissen. Na ja. Ja, wir hätten fast zu Fantasy geheissen. Aber das ZDF war dagegen.
Wir hätten fast Trashpanda geheissen.
Naja. Wir hätten fast
Flight of the Flamingo geheissen.
Rückblickend, sehr, sehr lustig.
Ich fand Jagd-TV auch ganz gut.
Jagd-TV ist so ein Scheissname.
Stefan wollte, dass wir Jagd-TV
heißen, mit so Y-A-K
und dann hat das Logo auch so Hörner,
wie ein Jagd.
Ich fand's clever. Ich fand's smart. das gegenteil von clever ist offensichtlich das war der gag ja gut und
dann hat dieser account auch den besten gegner zeiten randomly produziert und zwar einfach nur
ein tweet eine klare aussage 50 milli Milliarden Faves, Ostrich Wars.
Ostrich Wars, die Pfauenkriege, Strausenkriege, die grossen Strausenkriege. Also geil daran ist natürlich erstmal Strauss an sich und auch der Begriff Wars, nicht Ostrich War, sondern Ostrich Wars, also wirklich über langen Zeitraum, mehrere Kriege. Ich finde aber auch, das Tier ist perfekt. also es ist ausgewählt komödiantisch. Stell dich mal so ein Heer aus Draußen vor, die gegeneinander kämpfen. Auf allem die gucken auch immer so wütend. Das ist auch gefährlich. Die gucken mega wütend und von denen könnte man sich auch vorstellen, dass sie einfach wütend eine schlagkräftige Streitmacht zusammenstellen. Und deswegen dachten wir es immer mega lustig, haha, und haben uns tatsächlich auch kurzzeitig überlegt, uns so zu nennen, wobei allerdings dann irgendwann unsere Redakteurin mal alle Namenvorschläge vorgelesen hat und den Namen vorgelesen hat, als Ostrich war's. Also so wie, wer war's, Ostrich war's und der Name Ostrich, so wie Heinrich Ostrich. Große Ernstesitzung, viele Bosse da, Ostrich war's und wir beide so in der letzten Reihe. Ja, und diese und viele andere Gründe haben dann dazu geführt, dass er gesagt hat, nein, wir geben uns den Namen Gute Arbeit. Fanden wir auch lustig, auch eine Idee aus unseren Kreisen, aber eigentlich rückgibt eine Scheissidee, weil niemand was damit anfangen kann mit diesem Namen. Naja, aber darum ging es ja sowieso. Gut, und das ist die Backstory. Jetzt haben wir einen Artikel gefunden, auf seiner Science-Seite, und der ist wirklich eine Enttäuschung. Und zwar erstmal, die Überschrift ist mindboy, ich dachte mir, jetzt mein Leben wird auf den Kopf gestellt. Die Überschrift ist The Great Emu War of 1932 is as weird as it sounds. Es gab einen, ein Verwandter von Strauss, Emu-Krieg. Das ist unfassbar. Es gab 1932, gab es einen Emu-Krieg. War eine turbulente Zeit. 1932 waren viele aufgebracht. Ja, viele haben auch so ein bisschen das Vakuum der Geschichte gespürt und dachten, jetzt ist meine Zeit. Jetzt ist meine Zeit gekommen. Und auch viele Emus dachten sich, hey, die fucking Menschen beherrschen die Erde seit tausend von Jahren. Auch wir haben keinen Bock auf Juden, wir wollen auch mal Gehör finden und haben sich aufgestellt und informiert. Und was ist dann genau passiert, Stefan Tietze? Ja. Entschuldigung. Und mir fängt es an, enttäuschend zu werden. Und zwar kam einfach eine, es gab so eine Art Plage und es kam zu einem grossen, ich glaube so 20.000 Emus sind einfach über so eine Stadt gerannt und haben dann, die sind einfach so, die haben einfach so eingefallen, weil deren Territorium zu klein wurde und es waren waren einfach sehr viele Tiere. Und dann sind die einfach in so ein Stadtgebiet eingedrungen. Und man konnte einfach, man hat einfach die Jagd auf die eröffnet mit Gewehren. Und ich dachte, erstens, die Uncool, ich dachte, die kriegen gegen andere Tiere. Klar. Zum Beispiel gegen Löwen oder so. Straussen gegen Löwen, megacool. Ja. Das wäre schon ziemlich geil. Aber gibt's denn auf Wikipedia auch so eine Schlachtenseite, so mit Befehlshaber und Verlusten auf beiden Seiten, so wo man das genau gegenüberstellen kann? Das weiß ich nicht. Das finde ich interessant. 20.000 Emus stormed into the region as a part of the breeding season activities, finding the waterlocked agricultural lands of Western Australia, particularly homely.
They rapidly set up shop, stealing as many.
Set up shops?
They rapidly set up shop, das steht ja einfach, ich weiss nicht genau, der Satz war für mich auch zu früh vorbei, dass ich ihn verstehe.
Stealing as many of the crops as they could and generally causing pandemumium. Ja, forget it.
Stealing crops, finde ich auch schon mal gut, stealing crops. Die haben dann Shops eingenommen, auch mitgenommen. Die haben sich Souvenirs mitgenommen, geklaut, viele waren sauer, haben alle Hotelzimmer eingenommen. Also da muss man sich das unangenehm, ich stelle mir das als Stadtbewohner auch unangenehm vor. Schau mal vor, du kommst abends nach Hause, guckst in den Horizont, noch mal kurz am Schlafen gehen, bis jetzt noch mal am Balkon stehst, noch mal atmest tief ein, die Nacht ein, bis gerade das Fenster zu machen und am Horizont siehst du plötzlich so eine wütende Meute Emus mit so einer fackelnden Neugabe an der Stadtgrenze. Komisch. Alle denken, Emu cool, aber halt wenn es zu viele sind, wird es halt einfach zu krass. Ja, der Overkill, Entschuldige, aber es ist echt gut, aber Kratzer zu essen. Für euch wahrscheinlich nicht, aber für uns. Der größte Tier-Overkill hatte ich bei den Marienkäfern. Als Kinder liebt man den Marienkäfer. Alle sehen unterschiedlich aus, alle haben unnötigliche Anzahl von Punkten hinten drauf. Da ist was zu entdecken, da ist was dabei, da ist was dran. Und dann war ich an der Ostsee und da gab es eine Marienkäferplage dieses Jahr. What? Da war ich in Scharbeutz an der Ostsee. Und das war echt strange, ey. Also wirklich Milliarden von Marienkäfern. Manchmal war einfach so ein Strand, war einfach so ein Fell orange. Aber es war so furchtbar und so widerlich. Und vorm Urlaub habe ich die noch so auf die Hand genommen, oder war ich noch kleiner und fand das toll und habe die fliegen lassen. Nach dem Urlaub, Cut nach dem Urlaub, habe ich diese Baseballschläger genommen, diese massiven, die aus Holz waren und einfach so in so eine Menge Marienkäfer einfach reingeschlagen, weil es so viele waren, habe die einfach so auch in der Luft einfach so weggeschlagen. Das war so unangenehm, diese Anzahl. Und Tiere sind ja niedlich, aber eine Menge sowas, eine Menge Hundewelpen, furchtbar. Aber hast du dann auch so die Punkte gesammelt, als Trophäen? Ja, ja, habe ich mir getragen. Ich habe mir Gesichtsschmuck draus gebastelt. Krass, aber Marienkäfer sind das ja wie Maikäfer, oder? Nein. Was sind die Marienkäfer? Das sind die roten mit den schwarzen Punkten. Ja, das sind Marienkäfer. Und was sind Maikäfer? Maikäfer sind so dicke Braune. Ah, die sind auch unangenehm, aber auch in einst einfach. Eine einfache Ausgabe. Ein einfacher Gegner, kein Match für Stefan Titzler. Die cleverste Seite im Internet ist Japanese Bugfights, wo die einfach verschiedene Insekten gegeneinander kämpfen lassen. Mega brutal, mega wider die Natur, einfach eine furchtbar illegale Seite auch, aber die haben halt die geniale Idee gehabt, so Hirschkäfer gegen einen Skorpion zum Beispiel kämpfen zu lassen, eine Tarantel gegen eine Gottesanbeterin hochgiftige kämpfen zu lassen. Und vor allem die haben ganz kleine Kameras, so dass es dann im Verhältnis wieder so aussieht, als wären die riesengroß, und dann machen die auch echt Bas. Ganz kleine Menschen um den Ring herum. Ja, und die stacheln die dann irgendwie an, glaube ich, weil sonst warum sollten die sonst anfallen, diese Tiere. Und dann kriegen die sich halt das härteste. Und immer gewinnt der Hirschkäfer. Ah, der mit dem grossen. Der gute europäische Stier, schöne Hirschkäfer. Der ist so der Sichlor, oder? Der ist Sichlor, oder? Ja, der hat so diese Zange. Der hat vorne oben diese Zange und der hat also kein Tier hat also eine Chance, weil er die in der Mitte durchbeisst. Krass. Aber könnte man so auch einen Godzilla, ich drehe mir schon mal gerade so einen Godzilla-Film vor, so eine Eidechse, die einfach durch so eine Modellbaustadt läuft. Aber die sieht nicht so bedrohlich aus, ne? Eidechse. Man muss halt nur so ganz kleine Kameras haben. Ja. Ich glaube, so wurde Godzilla-Loch gedreht. Das Krasseste, was es bei Lego je gab, also Lego ist ja solide, aber Lego hat schon so ein paar Highlights gehabt, so absolut krasse Highlights, wo du denkst, wow. Und Lego hatte auch mal so eine Kamera, so ein Kameraset, wo du dir auch so ein Studio bauen konntest, und dann hattest du eine kleine Kamera, die du halt in dein Studio setzen konntest, und dann hat die so Filme gedreht. Ehrlich? Mega krass, wollte ich immer haben, habe ich nie bekommen, weil ich schon 19 war. Und das war einfach cool, weil ich mir denke, ah, genial, weil alles, was die Kinder schon haben, diese ganzen Lego-Sets, die Autos und Flugzeuge, gibst du noch mal eine komplett neue Dimension durch diese Kamera, weil dann können die das nochmal anders denken als Filme und so und es dann selber inszenieren und ein grosses Monster macht das Haus kaputt und so. Aber nimm die auf? Ja, ja. Und es ist kleiner. Ja, es ist eine echte kleine Kamera. So, die konnten es dann halt einfach in dein Lego-Set bestellen. Mega gut. Ja, ich glaube, die ist so groß wie die GoPro halt. Warum bauen wir ein großes Set hier auf? Ja, ich habe dir eh gesagt, so ein Sketch mit Actionfiguren, Sketch mit Actionfiguren und Lego-Figuren. Ja, komm. Ein Lego-Sketch fände ich mega gut einfach. Das ist total simpel umzusetzen. Und dann kommen die Duplo-Leute rüber und dann werden die so vertrieben aus Rassismusgründen. Die Lego-Menschen hassen die Duplo. Aber was es zum Beispiel auch gab von Lego war der Geschwindigkeitsmesser, der so eine Art Achse, wo du eine Achse durchgesteckt hast und dann konntest du die Achse in dein Auto bauen und dann konntest du dein Auto irgendwie anschieben und dann konntest du danach sehen,
wie schnell sich die Achse gedreht hat. Dann musst du noch die
Radgröße einstellen und
dann konntest du die Kmh rauslesen.
Das war mega geil einfach.
Ich hatte auch so viel Spaß. Ich hatte eine grosse Ritterburg,
war toll und irgendwann,
aber es war nicht mehr Lego, hatte ich
das tollste Spielzeug aller Zeiten, und zwar das
Labor von Professor Snape
in Miniatur mit Tränken, die du selber nachmachen konntest. Dann gab es verschiedene Lebensmittelfarben und Chemikalien und da konntest du halt, da war das halt so ein grosser Turm und da konntest du auch ein bisschen kochen drin und dann konntest du verschiedene Kessel gehabt, wo du verschiedene Chemikalien reinmachen konntest und die konntest du dann vermischen, dann fing die an zu qualmen oder zu grün, zu bruddeln, zu bruseln, zu bruseln, zu bruseln. Und es war ganz toll, dieses Spielzeug. Und man kennt das ja, aus der Kindheit bleiben oft viele Spielzeuge dann über, die entdeckt man dann irgendwann mal so. Und das war, also ich habe diesen Strang aufgeräumt und da habe ich eine Karrierabahn gefunden, alles cool. Und dann sieht man so grün leuchtend in der Ecke, massiv stinkend. Es strahlt immer noch. Es strahlt immer noch. Es glaube ich auch, mittlerweile habe ich da einfach Uran erschaffen. Dieses Professor Snape's Labor und es hat sich verselbstständigt, also da sind Tränke entstanden. Ich will nicht wissen, was man damit machen kann. Ich glaube, da waren auch diese Zeichen drauf, so Fische sterben und ätzend und so. Das war auch nicht zum Trinken, das war einfach nur für diese Effekte, die man machen konnte. Aber sowas Kindern zu geben, und das war, also wirklich, das hat sich aufgelöst, es hat in die Wand hat sich reingefressen, dieses Labor, so ein kleines, süsses Spielzeuglernen. Das hat sich auch so bewegt, so, Mama, töte mich, töte mich! Seit Jahren leidet dieses Monsterwesen, was erstanden wurde. Aber ich bin echt gespannt, wohin Harry Potter noch führt, weil ich meine, Fantastic Beasts war mega lame, weil alles noch in dieser Harry Potter-Welt gespielt hat. Ich glaube, es wäre cool, wenn Harry Potter einfach so einen Move macht wie Star Wars, sagen, hey, wir lassen den ganzen alten Schrott hinter uns, neue Regisseure, Fans der Serie, die das Ganze weitermachen, cool und weiter. Dass man einfach mal sagt, Harry Potter in einer modernen Welt. Harry Potter, nicht Harry Potter als normales Kind kommt in die Zauberwelt, sondern so Zauberkind kommt in die normale Welt, muss dann in die Schule gehen, kann aber zaubern, oder irgendwie Atomkraftwerk, Atomkrieg, kann aber so Accio, Atombombe, bam, kann dann irgendwie so Expegermus, Protonus beschwören. Aber alles in dem Universum, das man schon kennt, das würde sich jeder angucken, weil jeder sich solche Fragen stellt, wie Oda, Dementor beschwören irgendwie auf der Hauptschule, sowas passiert da.
Noch weiter gedacht, Harry Potter bei einer Science-Fiction-Welt.
Also will ich, dass ich mit Raumschiffen rumfliegen, aber halt alle die krassesten Zaubersprüche immer noch drauf haben und halt so altmodisch diese Kriege führen.
Aber ich stelle mir so ein Heer aus so mega technisch advanzen Leuten, die voreinander reinrennen, aber alle haben noch diese Zauberstäbe und haben da auch schon mittlerweile so Cyborg-Apparaturen dran und kämpfen gegeneinander, sonst sind sie Future-Harry Potter. Ey, ich meine, sehen wir es ein, zum Großteil der Kinoeinnahmen werden momentan mit Franchises gefahren. Franchises ist gleich Geld, weil die Leute es schon kennen und deswegen angucken, egal ob der Film gut ist oder nicht. Aber diese Franchises verlieren ja irgendwann auch wieder an Wert und dann wird wahrscheinlich auch die Phase kommen, wo sich irgend so ein Stuhl denkt, ja gut, wir haben jetzt noch dieses Avengers-Franchise, das noch so halb gut ist. Entschuldigung. Und wir haben noch dieses Herr-der-Ringe-Franchise, das auch so halb gut ist. Mash-up! Und dann gibt es so Mash-Up-Universen. Was ist der letzte Marvel-Film? Was ist der letzte Marvel-Film? Dann hast du da Simpsons und Floodje Griebig und alle einfach drin. Und dann sagst du, das hab ich schon mal gehört. Keine Ahnung, Avengers würde ich mir jetzt nicht unbedingt den nächsten angucken und Hedringer auch nicht unbedingt, aber zusammen, geil, das muss ich sehen. Und dann hast du noch unendlich viele Permutationen von allen Franchises, die dann auch so dreifach und vierfach sind. Ich frag mich ja, wann wagen solche Franchises zum ersten Mal einen, ich nenne es mal, das ist cool zu Wort dafür, einen Distinctive Regisseur zu nehmen. Also jemanden, der für einen speziellen Stil steht. Ich meine da sowas wie, nee, ich meine da eher sowas wie Tarantino oder Wes Anderson mässig oder David Lynch. Wann kommen mal solche Leute, die mal diesen Marvel-Film machen oder auch mal so einen Star Wars. Ich meine, es gibt jedes Jahr einen Star Wars-Film. Wie unwahrscheinlich ist es, dass Wes Anderson mal irgendwann einen Star Wars macht und wie cool wäre das denn mal? Weil ich meine, bei Comics machen wird das andauernd gemacht. Diese Comic Kultur ist insofern geil,
weil du halt immer wieder neue Künstler hast, die das halt zeichnen und so.
Manchmal hast du wirklich crazy Ideen.
Dann gibt es wirklich von
DC gelabelte
Superman-Comics, wo der einfach
sich auch mal verletzen kann.
Oder mal sagen kann, der ist jetzt
betrunken. Oder einfach so ganz
interessante Experimente. Und es sieht auch alles ganz anders aus als die anderen Comics, die auch Superman sind. Wo ich mir denke, ja, das ist doch der geilere Weg. Warum immer ein kongruentes Kosmos bauen? Warum muss es einen Kanon bei Star Wars geben? Warum kann nicht jede coole Geschichte, die irgendwie cool ist, erzählt werden? Warum muss alles zusammenpassen? Und warum kann man nicht mal einen Royce-Andersen-Star Wars machen? Und der sieht halt auch so aus, wie er, weil das von ,,Weris-Andersen ist", aber es ist halt auch genau so ein Star Wars wie der andere auch. Ich finde das einen coolen Weg, dieses Serielle mal aufzubrechen, insofern, dass man einfach sagt, eine Geschichte ist erzählensweit, also drehen wir sie so. Finde ich gar nicht. Frage ist halt, ob die nicht dafür schon zu uncool sind. Also Leute wie Quentin Tarantino Bock haben auf einen Superman-Film. Also wenn er jetzt wirklich alles neu, also auf die Figur hätte er vielleicht schon Bock, zu sagen, okay, da mache ich mein eigenes Ding draus, aber so wie es momentan... Es wurde ja auch viel damit mit solchen Figuren gemacht, weil es einfach auch cool ist. Also Superman ist einfach eine coole Figur, weil wie cool ist ein Protagonist, der theoretisch alles kann? Eigentlich eher uncool. Mega uncool, aber darin liegt ja genau die Stärke, zu sagen, wie kreativ muss man denn sein, um so eine Geschichte erzählenswert zu machen?
Bei jemandem, der eigentlich alles kann.
Da liegen schon spannende Fragen, finde ich.
Ich bin echt gespannt, wie das sich entwickelt.
Weil, was ist,
erst mal die Frage, was ist der letzte DC-Film?
Ohne Scheiss, wahrscheinlich
der 2018,
bevor Kim Jong-Un die Welt untergehen lässt.
Aber was wäre,
wenn man das mal so weiterdenkt, der letzte DC-Film? Locker ist es einfach ein Film gegen alle Marvel-Helden. Und das wäre schon geil. Da auf einen Schluck Mate. Das Kino geht unter. Wohin soll es hängen? Es gibt irgendwann nur noch Netflix. Aber ist ja auch nichts anderes als Kino. Ich hatte letztens so eine Brille auf, die ist so irgendwie Augmented Reality gedöhnt, super krass. Normale Brille, du siehst einfach nur sehr schlecht. Dreidimensional hat man damit gesehen. Wahnsinn. Und die hat halt so kleine, wie so Projektoren im Rahmen, die dir halt direkt in die Augen projizieren. Und dann guckst du halt so eine Wand an und dann sieht es so aus, als wäre halt an die Wand irgendwas rangebeamt und du kannst wie ein Beamer, kannst du halt das angucken und das wird aber auch deine Augen projiziert. Hä? Ne, also du, es ist halt wie wenn du das Bild im Raum hast. Aber du kannst auch theoretisch einen Schrank angucken und dieses trotzdem das Bild. Ja, genau. Also das ist halt so, wie würde das Bild einfach so vier Meter vor dir schweben. Aber du kannst dabei gehen. Du kannst dabei gehen, alles so. Das ist ja mega geil. Aber du hast das Bild immer direkt vor dir. Du kannst in der U-Bahn gucken, in den Film gucken. Ja, absolut. Und aber auch die Welt checken. Ja, absolut. Kannst du auch Auto fahren und den Film gucken? Die Legalität habe ich nicht. Aber das wäre super geil. Die sieht halt mega bescheuert aus, so ultra bescheuert. Also ich glaube, in der U-Bahn da sitzen ist es ein bisschen schwierig. Aber da ist auch so. Aber da habe ich mir auch gedacht so, ey, irgendwann musst du echt nicht mehr in Kino gehen, weil du kannst ja einfach, wenn du im Kino eine 3D-Brille aufsetzt, du kannst ja auch einfach eine Brille aufsetzen, die das Bild erzeugt. Dann brauchst du eigentlich das Kino selber gar nicht mehr. Gut, Ton und so, aber wenn du Kopfhörer auffasst, kannst du auch schon einen ziemlich guten Ton erzeugen. Irgendwie passiert alles nur noch in meinem Kopf. Aber ich dachte mir, das bewegt sich ja mit deinem Kopf mit, das Bild. Und da ist schon die Frage, ob du das haben willst. Du wackelst sehr viel mit deinem Kopf. Ob du das haben willst. Oder ob gerade dieses Außen-in-der-Welt-Sein wichtig ist für das Konsumieren des Films. Oder ob das, wenn es genau bei dir vor dir ist, ob es dann nicht ein anderes Erlebnis ist. Aber an sich kann man das ja wahrscheinlich auch so mit Gyroskopen und sowas dann auch machen, dass es sich nicht mitbewegt oder so. Aber das ist schon krass. Und dann denke ich mir irgendwann, okay, dann brauchst du kein Kino mehr, wenn du das wirklich krass machst. Und dann brauchst du eigentlich auch keine Kinos mehr. Und dann hast du alles auf Netflix. Ich finde aber, dass diese Aktion ins Kino gehen so wichtig. Dass man halt diesen Gang dahin hat, diesen Gang zurück, dieses Nachdenken darüber, dieses viel Opfern um den Film konsumieren. Aber du gehst auch jetzt weniger ins Kino als vor fünf Jahren, oder? Nee, geht so. Echt nicht? So mit Netflix und so und so Sachen angucken und dann bleibe ich lieber zu Hause und geht der Serienboom und so, der auch noch mal viel Zeit frisst? Ja, schwierig zu sagen, ja. Aber ich weiß gar nicht, was die offiziellen Zahlen sind, ob da Kinobesuche steigen oder sinken, können auch steigen, keine Ahnung. Keine Ahnung. Das ist schon spannend. Aber lass mal da so einen Forscher, so eine Zukunft, lass mal einen Fuss-Zukunftsforscher ein Gibt es da eigentlich Zukunftsforscher? Jeder forscht doch in die Zukunft. Außer man ist jetzt Historiker oder so, der in die Vergangenheit forscht, aber auch so Biologen überlegen sich, was könnte sein. Und nicht, ja manche natürlich auch schon, wie waren die Dinosaurier und was sind eigentlich Flügel, Lachflügel, was sind Schmetterlinge eigentlich, was soll das? Oh, die haben jetzt so ein Lamm gemacht, die haben Lamm in einer Plastiktüte gezeugt, also nicht mehr in einem Mutterleib, sondern in einer Plastiktüte haben die so ein künstlich befruchtetes Lamm komplett ausgebrütet, in einer Plastiktüte.
Ach was, das ist schon krass.
So wie deine Mutter oder was?
Ja gut.
Die Gag-Flaute. Warst du mal so richtig auf See eigentlich?
Ich meine, war so richtig schön, hast du mal Flaute gehabt, hattest du mal richtig, oh, jetzt eine Untiefe.
Warst du mal vor Anker so richtig? Nee, aber ich bin mit der Fähre ab und zu gefahren, aber jetzt nicht vor Anker. Merkst du, das brut, ah, ich glaube, nein, was soll man das bedeuten? Ich hätte eine ganz komische Rede, wenn man das vorben, aber das ist wie auf Schalke, man spielt auf Schalke und vor Anker. Okay, ja gut. Also die Fussballleute werden es verstehen.
Aber ich glaube, wenn ich Geld habe, mal irgendwann so richtig, ist das Erste, was ich mir hole ein Boot.
So ein richtig schönes Boot einfach und dann schipper ich rum.
Ich finde das so entspannt, diese Flaute, dieses Ruhige.
Stell dir vor, du sitzt auf dem Boot, um dir rum das Meer und du hast diese hässliche Brille auf und projizierst in das Meer Star Wars Rogue One und schaust dir Star Wars im Meer an.
Das ist schon abgefahren.
Als wäre es ein Freilichtkino im Meer.
Dann nervt das Schaukeln die ganze Zeit.
Ja, aber du kannst ja auch einfach vor Anker gehen, dann schaukelst du nicht mehr.
Aber das würde ich so gerne mal, so richtig schön ein Boot haben und dann kannst du halt diese Freiheit, du bist nicht mehr an Strassen gebunden zum Beispiel, du kannst einfach geradeaus fahren.
Ja, aber du bist an das fucking Meer gebunden.
Ja, genau. Und dann kannst du auch nicht überall, du bist auch auf Meerstrassen gebunden, weil du kannst nicht einfach in so eine Route reinfahren, wo so ein großes Boot, so ein Riesentrum.
So ein Öltanker.
So eine Aida, die sind auch schnell.
Aida!
Die sind wahnsinnig schnell. Holy moly. Ich habe einen Podcast gehört, wo jemand von einer Kreuzfahrt erzählt hat, die er auf einem Disney-Ride gemacht hat als Kind, als kleines Kind. Und früher waren diese Disney-Cruises, diese Seefahrten wohl nicht so wahnsinnig toll. Und er hat das als wahnsinnig widerliches Ereignis seiner Kindheit beschrieben, weil überall, es waren selten Erwachsene anzutreffen und selten Leute, die sich verantwortlich fürs Schiff gefühlt haben. Und überall war da Dreck rum, im Pool waren wirklich Fäkalien, im Whirlpool. Vielleicht war es auch die Toilette, die größte Toilette der Welt, man weiß es nicht. Im Wh du plötzlich so eine Schachtel Huber-Bubber rum und so. Nein, das habe ich gerade. Auch nicht schlecht. Das ist das, was mir angefallen ist. Aber ich weiß auch nicht. Als widerliches ist der Huber-Bubber eigentlich. Ich finde dieses Wort Schöpfen. Autor Stefan Teetze. Da ist halt ein bisschen so was rumgeschwommen. Auch Fäkalien und Haare und so. Aber nirgendwo war jemand, der mit dem Angespr Überall waren immer nur Pluto und Mickey, all diesen Walking-Characters. Entschuldigen Sie, Herr Pluto, ich habe da so eine Spritze in meinem Arm. Ernsthaft, irgendwie, mir ist ganz schwindelig und ich glaube, in der Spritze war noch was das Rennen. Ich meine, bitte sein Futter mal! Überall war Dreck, überall lagen die Leute bewusstlos rum und nie so, ich bin so ein Horrortrip.
Stell dir mal vor, dann gehst du so hin, die bebrochenen Käften, wir müssen zum Käften, dann gehst du so rein und plötzlich ist da einfach nur Donald Duck.
Ja, dieser schwarz-weiß Mickey Maus, du, du, da so, nein, nein, wir werden sterben. Aber was für eine furchtbare Sache. Aber deswegen finde ich auch immer bei den Simpsons, eigentlich die coolste Figur ist Krusty, eigentlich auch immer mit seinen ganzen merkwürdigen Produkten und seinem Freizeitpark, wo alles schiefläuft und dem Erziehungscamp, wo dann Sklavenarbeit ist, wo einfach alles furchtbar ist. Deswegen finde ich es eigentlich ganz cool. Also Krusty ist einer meiner Top 10 Simpsons-Figuren. Warum wollen wir eine Top 10 Simpsons-Figur machen? Oh, aber da müssen wir staffeln. Wir machen eine Top-40. Top-40 Simpsons-Figuren. Top-Nummer-40. Schneeball. Quagmire. Gut, Platz Nummer drei. Oh, das war schwer. Top-5-Simpsons-Figuren. Oh, Dr. Hibbert. Nee, aber dann würde ich sagen, dann würde ich einmal den Trumpf auffahren, nämlich Doktor Nick. Doktor Nick! Doktor Nick! Doktor Bob! Die erste June-Camp-Referenz. Auf Platz Nummer vier Hans Maulwurf. Oh ja. Ja, ja, ja, der Maulwurfmann ist schon super.
Ich bin nicht so ein Simpsons-Nerd.
Cool, dann schneiden wir die letzten zehn Minuten einfach raus.
Wählt ihr früh ein.
Miss Krabappel. Krabappel. Ah, Edna Krabappel natürlich, ja.
Platz Nummer drei, Martin.
Ja, der ist schon cool.
Der ist lustig, weil er immer gemobbt wird.
Du kannst dich damit identifizieren, ne?
Ist auch so ein Drama-Typ, der in meiner Drama AG war.
Diese beiden Zwillings-Western sind lustig.
Die, da muss ich drüber lachen.
Platz Nummer zwei, Lenny.
Platz Nummer zwei, Karl. Bin ich nur drin im Game. Ich war immer Family Guy, immer Team Family Guy. Und Platz Nummer eins, Milhouse. Ach Gott, ja. Ich nehme, ähm ich nehm, ähm, ähm, Skinner. Oh, aber sehr interessant, dass du sagst, weil den einzigen richtigen Shitstorm, die die Simpsons-Serie jemals ausgelöst hat und unter ihren Fans, es gibt ja unter jedem Simpsons-Fan so die Diskussion, ich mach einen fucking Simpsons-Podcast, okay? Okay, ja. Nee, sag mal bitte. Jetzt fällt dir nichts mit A ein. Du suchst nach Antenne-Aliterationen, aber der fällt nichts ein. Es gibt keine Simpsons-Fingung mit A. Antenne Springfield. Nee, aber es gibt ja unter Simpsons-Fans die große Frage, ab wann wurden die Simpsons scheiße. Und ich glaube, die gängigste Meinung ist Staffel 8, 9 oder 7, da spalten sich so ein bisschen die Geister, manche auch 12. Du hast alle Sachen aufgezählt. Die haben ein paar Sachen rausgeschnitten, der hat alle 12 Staffeln aufgezählt. Nee, es gibt ja schon 29 oder so mittlerweile. Ach so, okay. Aber einen grossen Shitstorm, wo viele sagen, ab der Folge wurden die Simpsons schlecht, war die Backstory von Skinner. Dass Skinner eigentlich gar nicht Seymour Skinner ist, sondern die Identität übernommen hat und eigentlich anders heisst. Und das war so die Folge, wo sich viele Fans auf den Schlips getreten gefühlt haben, weil die Macher da auch gemerkt haben, dass die Figur Skinner mega beliebt ist aus irgendeinem Grund. dass alle Skinner lieben, also eine Nebenfigur, so der Rektor, weil man halt einen Rektor braucht, aber alle lieben Skinner so sehr, dass die dann richtigen Schützern bekommen haben und auch in vielen Simpsons-Enzyklopädien ist das eine der schlechtesten Folgen und der am enttäuschendsten Folgen überhaupt. Und für viele beendet diese Folge so ein bisschen die goldene Ära der Simpsons. Schreibt immer bitte in die Kommentare ab, welcher Staffel wurden für euch die Simpsons scheißert? Dankeschön. Ich bin da nie so reingekommen. Ich habe das immer als Kind auf ProSieben geguckt, immer so, ich glaube, ich kenne die meisten Episoden, also die Episoden, die ich kenne, habe ich bestimmt 18 Mal gesehen, mindestens. Aber es beschränkt sich, glaube ich, auf so 180 Folgen, wohingegen man ja wesentlich mehr kann, kennen sollte, als jemand, der auch Comedy macht. Aber, nee, bin ich nie so reingekommen. Ich fand dann immer Family Guy zu früh cool.
Ich habe mich dann darauf fokussiert.
Nee, Family Guy ist für mich klar die zwei irgendwie.
Also ich habe Simpsons natürlich viele mitverfolgt,
auch in der Jugend. Mein Bruder war ein riesengroßer Simpsons-Fan,
hat auch alle Simpsons-Folgen auf VHS aufgenommen,
hat mir diese Sammlung dann irgendwann verehrt.
Aber es ist auch vor allem antiproportional.
Wohingegen, wenn Simpsons immer schlechter wird,
wird Family Guy immer besser. Das kann sein, ja, das stimmt. Family Guy habe ich mir auch immer eine Staffel runtergeladen, die vierte, glaube ich, oder so, und habe dann angefangen, aber bin dann auch irgendwann hängen geblieben irgendwie. Ja, aber auf jeden Fall, nee, Simpsons ist wahnsinnig gut, auch die vielen verschiedenen Schichten, die man erst im Laufe der Zeit bemerkt, wenn man sich das jetzt nochmal anguckt, man kennt die Folgen ja auswendig, mehr oder weniger, aber jetzt, wo man nochmal zehn Jahre älter ist, merkt man so, holy crap, da sind echt richtig gute Gags drin. Als Kind, aber lacht man ja auch nicht. Hast du wirklich als Kind über Kommunisieren gelacht? Nee. Also auch sowas wie so Hey Arnold oder Duck oder auch so diese, man lacht da nicht drüber. Also weil die jetzt auch nicht unbedingt notwendigerweise lustig sind, so ha ha ha, jetzt so keine Ahnung, irgendwie Modern Family, Gag, Gag, Gag. Du hast ja auch in der Geschichte wegen geguckt. Genau, so eine Figur. Ich wollte wissen, wie Lisa in der Schule jetzt abschneidet dann in dem Test. Das war mir wichtiger als alles andere, als die Humorebene drin. Man hat schon gesagt, ich finde es lustig, aber man hat nicht so gelacht irgendwie. Weil es war, wenn dann, glaube ich, eher so als Kleinkind, das wäre so, also so Humorentwicklung ist, glaube ich, auch echt ein sehr interessantes Thema. Da können wir vielleicht auf dem Humorkongress. Ey, lass doch mal, ich will nicht hin dieses Jahr. Ey, Humorkongress in Basel dieses Jahr. Das ist am Wochenende, kannst du das machen einfach, im September. Komm, wir gehen nochmal rein. Ja, klar, wir melden uns an. Ja, okay. Humorkongress in Basel. Da stellen wir unsere Simpsons-Nerd-Fragen. Ey, dann bin ich mal gespannt. Auf welcher Staffel wurde Simpsons schlecht? Ich habe so scherzhaft zu dir gesagt, ja, wahrscheinlich gibt es dann auch so einen Clown-Workshop, hast du gesagt, und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, wahrscheinlich gibt es auch so ein Therapie-Ding dann da, so eine Humortherapie, so Lachen gegen den Alltagstress, so ein Scheiss. Und dann gucke ich in dieses Programm, das erste, was ich sehe, ist Clown-Workshop, das zweite, was ich sehe, ist Lachen als Therapie. Genau das. Alles klar, danke. Aber wir müssen nicht nur da teilnehmen, sondern wir müssen auch versuchen, da selber einen Vortrag zu halten. Die werden jetzt wahrscheinlich das schon geschlossen haben, aber wenn wir da sagen, wir kommen und uns informieren, wie wir das machen, oder ganz viele Zuschauer schreiben, wir wollen ein Panel von Podcast-UFO und wir dann wirklich so ein Panel machen und so eine Humorschule machen. Und dann kommen so Männer und Frauen dann rein, so Ältere, die in der Hand dann so gebolgt gehen mit dem Programmheft. Ja, wir wollten niemals zum UFO-Podcast, wir wissen nicht genau, was das ist. Ja, ich habe jetzt Krebs und Lebra und ab und zu so ein Lacher ist das einzige, was mir noch am Leben hält. Wie kann es denn, Joyce Ilke, Hundet der VH. Wie kann es denn lachen? Das stimmt. Das war eine unserer ersten guten Stories, DocTV. Ja, DocTV. Und dann, ja, ich wollte mal fragen, wie uns das Lachen helfen kann. Ich meine, neulich kam die Gertrude an. Haha, Luke Mockridge, hahaha, Family Guy Insider, hahaha, Meta, Meta, Meta. Und dann ist sie einfach vor mir in der Küche dann auch verstorben. Und da wollte ich jetzt mal fragen, wie kann man in solchen Szenen dann noch ... Spanns Maulwurf und Werner Herzog so ein bisschen? Ja, das ist ein Mitteldinger. Ja, ich wollte fragen, wo ist er? Massiv in die Jahre gekommen, da Werner Herzog. I don't believe. Diese App, mit dem wir gerade alle parodieren und so toll finden, diese Face-App, wo du dein Gesicht hast, das in Älter, das als Frau und das als Kind. Und Werbung im vierten Panel. Wollen wir das nicht mal machen jetzt mit Imitationen? So, Werner Herzog als Frau. Here we go.
Nee, ich will nicht meine heißgeliebte Werner Herzog-Imitation hier verschachern.
Well, this is Werner. Das geht nicht so gut.
Nee, das geht nicht. Das ist umgegangen.
Es ist allein schon sehr schwer, ihn auf Deutsch zu sprechen.
Das stimmt.
Das ist schon unmöglich.
Naja, ich weiss nicht um... Naja.
Du warst schon wieder in einem Rapper. Naja, ich weiss nicht, was ich sagen soll.
Ich weiss nicht, was ich sagen soll. Ich bin nicht so richtig gut. Impressionen machen und ich befehle einfach der Mut. Ich bin nur Stefan, das Fun steht für Spaß, das weiß ja jeder. Und jetzt sehe ich hier ein bisschen was vom Leder. Es ist so verrückt, wie Rappen einerseits das Coolste ist, was es gibt, und aber auch gleichzeitig das aller aller uncoolste, so wirklich so das maximal, ich rede nicht nur von Poetry Slam, sondern auch wirklich das schlechteste Rappen.
Ja, reimen, also wirklich so ein Erich von Hoffmannsthal, wo man wirklich in der Schule sagt so Gähn, Gähn, Gähn, Gähn, bis man ermahnt wurde.
Und aber heute irgendwie hier so dieser Eminem oder dieser Flavor Flav, was die heute droppen, ist ja mega krass. Die reimen, vor allem auch so Shakespeare, denke ich mir auch. Cool, coole Geschichten, aber warum müssen die alle reimen? Hast du dir wirklich gedacht, coole Geschichten bei Shakespeare? Nee. Zu meinem Ernst? Nee. Nee, ne? Shakespeare kann nix, Shakespeare kann nix. Nie ein Shakespeare-Fan gewesen, auch Goethe-Fan nicht. Nein, nein, nein. Ach ja, man muss vielleicht ein bisschen mehr lesen. Ja, ja, Kleist-Fan, großer Kleist-Fan. Ich auch, ich mag auch Kleist, die Hermannsschlacht. Super. Richtig gutes Buch, der ist aber auch ein Krug, ernsthaft. Ich bin großer Kleist-Fan und Dürrenmatt, finde ich super. Die können was für mich. Wir kennen uns schon so lange und ich wusste nicht, dass du Kleist-Fan bist, Alter. Ich gehe mit Haun nicht ausieren, ich habe mein Kleist-Tirt heute Morgen mal nicht angezogen. Ey, das ist schon geil. Der offizielle Autor des Podcast-Ufos ist Heinrich von Kleist. Dem haben wir das ja alles zu verdanken, in seinen grossen Geschichten. Ich hoffe, dass wir viele Bilder bekommen von eifrigen Hörern, die mit ihrem Reklam, die jetzt noch mal ihr Reklam-Heinrich-von-Kleist-Buch aus dem Regal und so zerbrochen. Ich habe auch noch mal, die können nicht gewissen. Die können wir mal verschärfen. Also ich würde die verlosen, würde ich das machen. Hier sind so ein paar Reklamheftchen, die würde ich noch mal verlosen. Nein, bitte nicht. An diesen Scheiß... Wir hängen jetzt immer noch an unsere letzte Verlose. Stimmt, aber immer noch. Aber ich habe auch noch so... Das Coole ist, wenn man diese Reklamheftchen, die habe ich manchmal auch gebraucht gekauft auf so Trödelmärkten, und da stehen immer noch so Anmerkungen drin aus der Schulzeit. Ja. So Ausrufezeichen drin. Wichtig, wichtige Passage, Achtung. Wichtig für die Klausur, Klausur 4. Mai. Hier begeht er das Obrigkeitsglauben, ist hier fehl am Platz. Ja. So Klausurrelevant Ausrufezeichen. In meiner Rubrik Storys, die wir alle schon kennen, möchte ich noch mal eine Story erzählen, und zwar von dem kreativsten Produkt, das ich jemals gesehen habe. Und zwar gab es von Reklam mal Notizhefte. Also so ein Reklam-Büchlein leer. Kannst du selber was reinschreiben. Geil. So, pass auf. Jetzt hat dieses Büchlein den Red Dot Design Award gewonnen. Also gutes Design wird immer prämiert mit dem Red Dot Design Award. Und wenn du den hast, dann darfst du auf deinem Produkt einen roten Punkt machen.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Jetzt haben die dieses Reklamheft, wo ja auch immer R-E-C steht für Reklam, haben dieses Reklam-Notizbuch und da stand R-E-C und dann dieser rote Punkt daneben. Bei REC steht ja auch für Rekord, genauso wie der rote Punkt auch für Rekord steht.
Und das ist ja ein Notizbuch, in dem man Dinge recordet. Und es ist der Red Dot Design Award. Da passt alles fucking zusammen. Das ist richtig gut. Das ist richtig gut. Das ist, ey, als ich das gesehen habe, ich dachte mir, Alter, ist das gut? Das passt so viel zusammen. Das ist so fucking gut einfach. Also wenn ihr das noch kriegen könnt, schaut mal auf Amazon vorbei und holt euch dieses Notizbuch, einfach um sagen zu können, ich habe das beste Objekt der Welt. Genauso, also bevor ich das gesehen habe, war da was anderes mein kreativstes Objekt der Welt, und zwar nämlich der, ja da war ich jünger, aber das Spiel Scrabble und das ist ja schon immer ganz geil. Und dann gab es dafür den Claim Scrabble, das beliebteste Wortspiel der Welt. Und das ist ein Wortspiel mit dem Wort Wortspiel. It's cleverste Wortspiel a la Wortspiel. Das ist so genial. Nicht das Kreativste, was ich je gesehen habe, aber als ich bei der Star Wars Celebration war. Oh Gott, ich wusste jetzt, dass Star Wars war. Sorry, tut mir leid, aber das war gerade letzte Woche passiert. Aber da waren halt so viele Cosplayer. Und dann gab es halt, dann gab es zwei Cosplayer, die haben sich halt als Leute verkleidet, die offensichtlich dem Sanitätsdienst angehören, die Cosplay-Kostüme reparieren. Das war so clever. Also Cosplay-Red-Cross-Leute einfach, die halt auch im Star-Wars-Kosmos sich angezogen haben. Red-Cross-Play. Sozusagen. Sich angezogen haben, so intelligent waren es dann noch nicht und so kreativ, aber die angezogen haben, die alle Werkzeuge dabei hatten, dann kam dann immer so ein Stormtrooper zu den, haben den repariert und das wieder angeschraubt und so. Das fand ich auch richtig kreativ. Aber wenn man sich als großes Brot verkleidet, ist man dann eigentlich ein Crossplay? Oder wenn man sich als großes Brot verkleidet mit einem Umhang, ist man dann ein Breadman? Nee, nee. Könntest du dir jemals vorstellen, ein Cosplay? Das ist immer so ein... Doch, doch, doch, doch. Aber da hatten wir es schon mal. Ich verstehe immer nicht, was man dann macht tatsächlich so. Ich mag es ja auch manchmal gerne, Kostüme anzuhaben. Ich habe ja die Ehre, einen Beruf zu haben, wo man oft Kostüme anhat. Man fühlt sich cool in einem Kostüm. Allein schon, wenn du so eine Polizeiuniform an hast, fühlst du dich cool. Du bist cool. Ich behaupte auch. Easy. Kann ich jedem nachvollziehen. Der Hauptmann von Köpenick ist so aktuell wie nie. Ich glaube, wenn du... Was ist das für eine Folge? Ich wette, wenn du dir eine Polizeioneform anziehst, eine originale, du hättest die maximale Macht, du könntest alles machen in Deutschland. Ich glaube, einfach, Leute haben noch so viel Angst und so viel Respekt vor Aussehen. Es gibt auch diesen Artikel von Weiss, habe ich auch mal jemandem erzählt, wo einfach ein Typ eine Warenweste anhatte und plötzlich dann bei Beyoncé in der ersten Reihe stand, in dem Graben davor, weil er eine Warenweste anhatte. Leute hatten Respekt vor einer Warenweste. So, wenn du eine Polizeiuniform bei der Film- und Theaterausstattung herholen kannst, dann easy. Aber das sind ja zwei verschiedene Ansätze. Eine Warenweste ist ja eigentlich eher ein soziales Understatement, weil das ja normale Arbeiter sind, die halt Bühnentechniker sind, wo die einfach nicht beachtet werden, weil die halt einfach ja die arbeiten hier. Wohingegen jetzt eine Uniform, eine Polizeieuniform ist ja eher ein soziales Overstatement, wo dann sagst du, oh, vor dem habe ich Respekt. In beiden Fällen schlüpst du in eine Gestalt, die dir Zugang zu Vorteilen in gewissen Situationen verschafft.
Das will ich damit sagen. Ich glaube, das ist einfach immer noch sehr aktuell.
Oder auch so ein Arztkittel. in einer Gestalt, die dir Zugang zu Vorteilen in gewissen Situationen verschafft. Das will ich damit sagen. Ich glaube, das ist einfach sehr, sehr, sehr immer noch sehr aktuell.
Oder auch so ein Arztkittel. Wir haben ja so
ein Lidl und ich musste ja immer,
weil es nie veganes Essen gab, muss ich mir manchmal bei Lidl
was zu holen, wenn wir gedreht haben.
Und das ist so cool. Im Arztkittel.
Teilweise ein Arztkittel, einmal war ich
so ein Alien-Typ, dann Polizist,
dann so ein Swat-Polizist, verschiedene
Sachen und du läufst darum, einmal so ein
abgefahrenes Alien-Ding und du läufst da durch und
ist einfach krass. Wenn du ein Arztkittel anhast, die Leute
Vielen Dank. so ein Alien-Typ, dann Polizist, dann so ein Swat-Polizist, verschiedene Sachen und du läufst darum einmal so ein abgefahrenes Alien-Ding und du läufst da durch und ist einfach krass, wenn du ein Arztkittel anhast, die Leute denken einfach, okay krass, der muss... Lassen die sich dann vor in der Kasse auch und so? Ne, das nicht, ihr habt dann irgendeine Hubba-Bubba-Päckchen und Gummibärchen. Hätst du da mit einem Arztkittel, was so blutüberströmt vorne ist, und einfach so mit den Handschuhen noch die Mango nimmst und dann noch die Kasse legst. Ja, naja, Mango so produzzierst. Heute war ein bisschen eine andere Folge, ne? Ja, mit Kratzeis und Kleist. Wow, das ist ein toller Folgentitel. Wie früher, in alten Zeiten. Möbel und Möglichkeiten, Chancen und Weisen nicht mehr was war. Deswegen, früher haben wir immer Alliterationen in den Titel. Deswegen sollten wir auch wieder machen. Leute, freut euch nicht so sehr auf Folge 100, weil wir wissen noch nicht genau, was kommt.
Aber bis dahin wünschen wir euch jedenfalls eine fantastische Woche.
Ich wünsche dir auch eine schöne Woche. Und viel Spaß bei eurem Leben, abseits dieses Podcast, denn das Leben geht jetzt weiter.
Und das Leben ist lebenswert auch, Leute. Geht mal raus, dieser Podcast ist nicht das Zentrum eures Lebens.
Das war jetzt gerade unsere Show, aber jetzt beginnt eure Show, euer Leben.
Oder der nächste Podcast.
Krampenlicht auf euch. Aufs Reden. in drei, zwei, eins, mach was draus.